make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our x-men
encyclopedia in this one I want to run
over the chronological history of
mutants in Marvel Comics um now for
those three guys who have been around my
channel for a little while you know that
we've kind of talked about this in
various forms like we did our x-men
explained and we touched on it we've
talked about characters like Gabriel
Shepard different things like that but
we haven't really done a comprehensive
history of mutants in Marvel Comics is
that's what we're gonna do here now this
really all kind of kicks off with what's
called the first host now we've talked
about the first host a bunch of
different times so if you're familiar
with that bear with me here on this but
the way this basically played out is
that in the universe you have what are
called Celestials now the Celestials
don't really have names I mean they they
do insofar as they give each other names
but we don't really know what they were
before they were Celestials all we're
kind of left to believe through a
combination of the old like Roy Thomas
stories and Neil Gaiman's Eternals and
looking at what Ally we did with the
Ultimates all we really got through
accommodation to those things is that
the Celestials basically came into
existence with the universe right there
they're always there if you go look at
he at the Ultimates by Al Ewing it's
more that they were created by the first
universe and then just kept being reborn
every time the universe or the
multiverse was recreated or universe was
destroyed and remade but by whatever
manner and whatever means the Celestials
came into existence and the result is
that they really became more of one
creators insofar as they created life
across the universe and then to they
would experiment on that life right so
there were scientists different things
like that and so while earth was not the
first planet they did it at they did it
a whole bunch of other different planets
to the scroll home planet and so on they
visited earth in in the very early days
of man roughly around one to one and a
half million years ago and what they did
is they encountered a group called The
Wanderers now the Wanderers were
basically Marvel's variation of this
missing link evolutionary stance of man
between primate and modern man right so
The Wanderers are basically gathered by
Gaia who was a living sentient of the
planet right like Mother Earth more or
less and then they were brought before
this this gathering of the Celestials
which it was gammon on the gatherer and
then he split them into thirds and then
handed one third to each different
celestial right so one group went to
zero on the tester the other one went to
went to nazar the calculator and the
last one went to Oneg the program now
when it came to zero on the tester what
he did is he he kind of mutated their
genes but all he did was destabilize
them and what that did was it created
that deviance right these troll looking
beings that were out there following
that you went into nazar who basically
created these like Eternals right these
heavenly beings
he's almost angelic in terms of how they
appear right they they have perfect skin
the abilities happened cosmic energies
and all kinds of cool stuff
and then you had Oneg de Pro work now
Oneg de Pro were planted a latent gene
writing the idea was that at some point
along the line of whatever comes after
these Wanderers this gene will manifest
and when it does that will give birth to
whatever it gives birth to and so that's
the reason why mama gives us characters
like The Incredible Hulk and it's why
Bruce Banner didn't die of radiation
sickness when he was hit with gamma rays
right this latent gene activated and he
became the Incredible Hulk and a lot him
to tap into all that wrath and anger he
had from the abusiveness that he
suffered at the hands of his father and
in the Incredible Hulk was born now from
there you start going into what's
basically hearsay and and kind of like
maybe it's true maybe it's not not so
much in the fan base but in so much is
how the stories are told
right so you had this guy named forever
man ah who simply makes a claim that he
was one of the first mutants to ever
exist right I mean you don't really know
anything about him all you know that is
that when he dies he does reincarnates
every single time without fail forever
man hasn't been seen for a while and as
far as I'm aware he doesn't exist and
Jonathan Hickman x-men run so there's no
real reason to believe that he's he's a
part of anything anymore
and you kind of get that a little bit
right I mean now you do get shadow king
and shadow king is one of these more
interesting characters because he's a
multiversal concept right so shadow king
exists in a way to where he's like the
Phoenix force right there's one Shadow
King that expands throughout the
entirety of the multiverse now if you go
based on on what we had seen like in the
old school well not really the old
school comics but if you go and you look
at what you saw with like x-men true
friends number two right let you kind of
get this explanation and this was a
story by the way that came out in 1999
so it's relatively old school but what
you basically get is this this
explanation from the shadow king that
like he's basically existed since the
dawn of man right but like if you go and
you look at other comics it's the shadow
king came into existence when the first
nightmare was experienced so the first
bad experience the first terrible
scenario or the first ounce of hatred or
something like that it kind of waxes and
wanes but the idea here is that the
Shadow King is really more of an
ethereal entity not really a mutant in
the traditional sense so I don't know
why people classify them that way but
then you start to go into Selene now
Selene is a character where it seems
like Hickman is kind of ignoring her
we're not a hundred percent sure and the
reason why is because in the most recent
iterations of house and powers of X the
most recent issues were simply told that
like Apocalypse was the first mutant now
this storytelling is told from the
perspective of krakoa
who's a living Island but just because
he's a living Island doesn't mean he
knows everything so it could be the
kokoa doesn't know it could be the
Jonathan Hickman is basically saying the
Selene is not actually a mutant it could
be that she doesn't exist
according to Jonathan Hickman she
doesn't exist as she doesn't count he's
kind of wiping her away from the pages
of the x-men we're not really sure yet
and we may never find out you know I'm
not really sure what direction he's
gonna go in there so you can kind of
take it for what you want but basically
Selene is around 17,000 years old and
she's largely considered to be the first
in continuity canon mutant which is to
say the first one that you can
consistently point to and say she was
the first mutant to be born in the
history of humanity from there you start
kind of fast-forwarding a bit you start
going into things like biblical times we
talked about the the Nayef m and the che
RM basically these mutants that look
like angels and demons and they kind of
waged a war against one another if you
get into uncanny x-men 422 429 433 you
basically discover there's like this old
school you know a group of mutants that
existed some 15,000 years ago again a
lot of that is kind of hearsay it's like
a thing that appears in one comic and
it's never expanded on after that right
it's just kind of there and you never
really find out what in the world is
going on so to kind of stick with
continuity we sort of fast forward to
about 5,000 years ago and we get in
Subodh noir now there are a couple
characters that we can kind of run over
there and you've got like different
individuals who have appeared but none
of them really seem to count at least as
far as I'm aware so got it going with in
Saban Newark we've talked about him
before we've got a video on apocalypse
explain what you guys are welcome to
reference it'll have a lot more
information about his character what
we're gonna cover here but the long and
short of it is that apocalypse was
essentially born with the ability to
alter his own mass and immortality but
in terms of his abilities he was pretty
baseline it wasn't until he discovered
celestial technology and then was
finally able to interact with it they
started modifying his own body right so
everything that apocalypse has outside
of the ability to alter his body's own
structure right to make you say
basically like grow in size to shrink in
size things like that and immortality
all that is artificial right all that is
basically external enhancements granted
to him that there were given to him by
some form of Technology from there
that's when you start going into more
more intriguing characters one of the
more intriguing characters that we
actually got out of this early era of a
man was actually a guy named Decimus
furious now
Decimus furious didn't really appear
until uncanny x-force issue number three
so he showed up like really more
recently and and much later on after the
original x-men but the idea was that he
was basically a guy whose powers
manifested in such a way that he
appeared to be a Minotaur and literally
was a gladiator at one point eventually
he was found he was discovered by
apocalypse and basically sealed away so
he could become one of his final
horsemen that took place during the Dark
Angel saga and even a little bit like
during the final horsemen saga is part
of like the apocalypse twins and those
care
and things like that during the uncanny
x-force storyline but again like you
kind of get these little bits and pieces
these characters that show up here and
there and then just kind of appear for a
little while and then for some reason or
another
basically vanish now from there you go
into like Bennett doop Harry basically a
guy who became Exodus he was an
individual who had these insanely
powerful telepathic powers that were
latent and then ultimately tapped into
by apocalypse and then eventually Exodus
became kind of a henchman for apocalypse
until he betrayed him and then was
locked away but Exodus was exceedingly
powerful right he was one of the most
powerful and and still is one of the
most powerful telepaths and telekinetics
across the entirety of the Marvel
Universe right I mean the guy's power is
absolutely insane but probably one of
the more interesting developments in the
history of the mutant chronology came an
x-factor volume three issue number 10
and this introduced something called the
changelings now up until this point
throughout the entirety of mutant
history the development of mutant powers
were either tied directly into an
emotional state so in the case of
apocalypse basically he was heartbroken
and then the emotional torment basically
sent his powers into overdrive and they
developed and so on and so forth or they
would just arbitrarily happened there
was no real rhyme or reason to it what
the changelings introduced by way of
this comic was the idea that heat and
power sort of manifesting at puberty now
the question is why didn't they
manifested purity before we're never
really given an answer we're simply just
told they were the ones that really
started developing powers through
puberty and they just kind of went from
there right now even even now it's not
an absolute thing right powers don't
always manifest new puberty that was
kind of the nature of what it is at Oneg
dah uh Oneg get done when it came to
planting this latent gene it was given a
timeline insofar as here's how long it
will take before this gene starts to
activate in terms of the evolutionary
progress of humanity but there was no
real standard on here's when this gene
will activate in the lifespan of a
single human right it's just somewhere
along the line it will just pop up but
following those guys and going more into
a pre 1000 year period so about a
thousand years ago you started running
into proto means now again one of the
things to keep in mind when it comes to
this this evolutionary history of
mutants is that for the most part you
had apocalypse who who first popped up
but he was only the first in one
geographical location there were others
popping up around the same time right
sunny within a few years of apocalypse
there were other mutants popping up or
at least presumably so we can kind of
make that assumption because of the fact
that like there are mutants in like
Macedonia and other places around the
world that apocalypse either didn't
visit or simply pass through or never
really woke the powers up for anybody
who lived there and so because of that
but when it comes to the proto Mew
all we know is that around premier
around seven eight hundred maybe nine
hundred years ago that's some group of
humans basically their powers awoke and
then they essentially became what were
proto mutants so that is to say the
predecessor to modern-day mutants right
so if apocalypse and people like him are
the mutant equivalent to the Neanderthal
then the proto mutants are kind of like
the missing link between what apocalypse
was and what modern-day mutants are now
the difference is that part of mutants
were all exceedingly powerful the
problem is there was no one there to
really teach them they just kind of
developed powers they were there and
that was basically it and they were not
indestructible right they could be
defeated only because they didn't really
have a full harness of what their
abilities were now a lot of this comes
by way of x-men vol 3 issue number 31
and that's simply just with the
introduction of like Gabriel Shepard
different things like that and all we
really have is Gabriel Shepards work
right like what he's what he told us
over the course of those particular
stories or at least that one particular
story and he simply kind of offers
himself as the most powerful of all the
proto mutants right so while a lot of
them were powerful and they were all
powerful in their own right
Gabriel Shepard was the most powerful of
them right so just because he could stop
time warp reality doesn't mean anybody
else could but regardless of the
scenario all of the proto mutants except
for Gabriel Shepard were wiped out when
they were all blamed for the black
plague in that region of the world and
so because of that you kind of just
start sort of going forward and you
really jump forward by like sometime or
you start going into the 15th century
you start going into the 16th century
the 17th 18th centuries and you start
getting these small areas we're like
mutants began to pop up again and again
that's the important thing to bear in
mind here is that really up until you
get to about the 19th century mutants
are just sort of sporadically introduced
and sporadically talked about in Marvel
Comics there's kind of there and there's
some things that happen and they're
never seen or heard from again and the
stories you get oftentimes aren't really
even reliable because the person giving
us that story is kinda like well maybe
is true maybe it's not you know who
really knows it's just hope for the sake
of telling a story but at this point we
jump to around the 15th century and this
is when we start getting more
interesting characters right so this is
when you start getting into the
character of Gideon now Gideon is really
one of the more interesting characters
that came from the history of cable
released cables introduction in the
marvel comics now but Gideon is an
example of what we call an external you
would look at apocalypse and you would
say okay apocalypse is a nice and
external and so far that he cannot truly
be camp truly die from any sort of
external means if you get into Gideon
and into what you basically learned here
is that individuals who are externals
don't always have the same power right
like the only constant theme
is immortality the inability to die from
age or disease but with someone like
Gideon he actually had the power to
mimic the powers of others right so it
was cool and so far as how he worked the
problem is that he was kind of a
hallmark of the 1990s
and so you didn't really see a whole lot
from him after his head was chopped off
by cable Marvel try to bring him back
more recently but as a product of the
90s he doesn't really fit in in today's
more modern stories but for what it's
worth he was certainly one of the more
prominent externals back then in terms
of his activities right so I mean he was
part of Columbus's expedition that came
to the United States and so on and so
forth but that's when you started
getting into things like like Sabretooth
that's where you start getting into
things like like Wolverine where the
various appearances of mutants were kind
of sporadic insofar as they would just
sort of popped up over the years what
this does is bring up much bigger
explosion of mutant population across
the world and the sense a mutant should
start blowing up at a much faster rate
now one of the big questions a lot of
people ask is why now right like why is
it one of these things where mutant
started exploding like this over the
years honestly I would argue that it's
really more due to this global
exploration right because there's a
reason why as you look through this as
humanity began to harness technology
that would allow them to explore the
world in a more direct way that mutants
started to appear more and more right so
he was sort of spreading to more of the
world which led to more intermingling of
different genomes which led to more
mutants being born again once you start
getting into this era you start getting
into like the 1800s and you start
getting into characters like mr.
sinister now Nathaniel Essex
traditionally is not a mutant what
really seems to be happening here with
with Jonathan Hickman is he seems to be
hitting on the idea that he is right
that this sinister is actually a mutant
and it's kind of interesting because it
could go either way the original story
is by of the adventures of Cyclops and
Phoenix Nathaniel Essex had powers
bestowed to him by apocalypse but what
Jonathan hitman could do is easily come
along wipe that away and say well powers
were bestowed only insofar as Apocalypse
woke up the latent gene of sinister and
this is the form he took but then you
start getting up to the 1900s when you
start getting into Burke Saul Absalom
Nicodemus and Gideon and again like
Gideon had already come into existence
the other ones basically formed a kind
of inner circle of the externals right
now this is not really a council that
existed so much is like they exist him
to like a singular sanctuary and they
just sort of dictated what they were
gonna do with the world or anything like
that they weren't like the Illuminati or
anything on those lines these are
basically it is kind of like a loose
circle insofar as they all share a
common trait and they're all aware of
the other's existence but then around
that time between 1891
to about 1900 that's when you basically
get into the birth of James Howlett
Wolverine that's when you get into Silas
burr that's when you start getting to
characters like ogen these are really
really interesting concepts he's these
really cool individuals who develop
their powers but going from the 1900s up
into the modern day that's when you got
this massive explosion of the mutant
population right and that's where any
other thing people ask I don't really
know what the answer to that question is
that's when you got this massive
explosion of the mutant population and
so far as you started getting like all
these characters born right so like
magneto was born in the 1920s you
basically had Wolfgang Hayek Heinrich
who was born in in the 1930s you had
like Amahl Farouk who basically started
becoming more active in the main Marvel
Universe at the turn of the century and
then going into the the world war 1 and
then during the World War 2 era or at
least pre World War 2 era um all these
these mutants who are basically
exploding in in prominence now a lot of
these mutants who existed uh during that
time especially during World War one and
World War two were thought to have been
some kind of like strange abnormality
and indeed they kind of wore in so far
as like they were the next step in human
evolution the issue is that at the time
humanity didn't really know what they
were they didn't really know how they
functioned or how any of that stuff
worked and so they kind of saw them as
more akin to like not really witches or
anything like that or like warlocks but
just as like unknown quantities and so
what you ended up having around that
time during World War one in World War
two is those individuals who were in
Europe and who were captured by Germans
during that time we're thrown into
concentration camps but instead of
making them into individuals who would
work instead they were handed over to
Nathaniel Essex who at this point was
operating under the moniker of mr.
sinister and then manipulating their
genes basically like like experimenting
on them doing all going all through
these like heinous experiments and
things like that but to kind of see how
their genes worked and what causes the
mutant gene to activate different things
along those lines so again you get into
some pretty dark times in terms of the
mutant population and the mutants
overall history but again getting into
characters like like Christopher North
right Christopher Nord is I care too
that not a lot of people have talked
about that we haven't really talked
about but basically his code name was
maverick he was part of the original
team X from the team that Wolverine
served on before he was inducted into
the Weapon X project but again like it's
one of these things where different
countries were trying to find a way to
basically cope with the mutant threat on
their own right so like the Soviet Union
initially always basically euthanizing
mutant children and and it was kind of
crazy because if you go back and you
look at the old stories of Colossus
before he was actually brought into the
action or at least not really old
stories they came after his original
introduction in giant-size x-men number
but if you go back and you look at his
origin stories one of the things that
that the Soviet Union was doing is they
were euthanizing mutant children because
they were afraid that they would rise up
against the Soviet Union and overthrow
the existing government it wasn't until
later on that they realized they could
be Hughes as a means to basically create
their own kind of elite fighting force
right like super-powered fighting force
now a lot of that was in response to
like the Avengers of the United States
and so that's why you know around the
time that Colossus was found in the mid
to late 1960s but what the Soviet Union
was doing was it was going around and it
was capturing anybody who was a mutant
and then forcing them and even
brainwashing them to become a servant of
the Soviet Union proper in the United
States you actually had project
wide-awake which we've talked about
before but in Canada you had to harm an
H and so he basically had Alpha Flight
different things like that but it was
basically this is this huge expansion
where humanity began to look at the
meeting population and see them as a
potential threat insofar as okay these
guys could potentially kill us we have
to get rid of them - looking at him and
saying but wait we can use them for our
own means and then moving forward
accordingly going into the mid 1960s of
course that gets us really closer to the
modern day you have Charles Xavier who
comes along and he basically have all
the stories of the x-men up to that
point now 412 Xavier this is a pretty
significant moment because this was
really the first time that a mutant with
the ability to rally together a team
came into contact with the shadow king
often to that point those individuals
who were possessed by the Shadow King
we're thought to have been possessed by
see right like possessed by like a demon
or something like that and usually where
there were attempts to kill him off
sometimes the shadow king would wipe out
an entire village you know sometimes it
was successfully managed to kill the
host but regardless of the circumstance
during that time after Xavier had met
magneto the two of them parted ways and
then Xavier went on his own he ended up
travelling to Egypt and he met Amahl
Farouk who of course was the host body
for the shadow king and that was when
Xavier realized that there were some
mutants out there who couldn't be
bargained with all he wanted to do was
basically just inflict as much hatred
and pain as they possibly could and then
he basically treat them that way and
banned a team together that could defeat
mutants like that whether you start
going into again it's this sort of
expansion I mean at this point it's
really more the modern-day the modern
era of mutants getting us up to like the
launch of the x-men mutants who were
cropping up mutants who are doing their
own thing mutants who were who are
coming becoming part of the x-men team
or else join Magneto and his Brotherhood
of Evil Mutants possibly even becoming a
part of the Hellfire Club because we're
on this town remember you've got the
birth of Emma Frost you've got the birth
of Sebastian Shaw Donald Blake you've
got a lot of these guys out there who
were who are basically kind of coming
out and and and developing their own
their own history I mean from that point
it kind of gets us into the modern day
so we can probably sort of stop here but
in terms of the chronological history
there are some things we left out here
and there but again a lot of that stuff
is just sort of hearsay it's just sort
of like there's a character in a comic
book who makes a claim and we don't
really know if it's true or not we just
kind of have to sort of go with what
seems to be in continuity right I mean
carriage like date can be in boring 1946
yes you know I mean you go back and you
read something like Wolverine Weapon X
Files number one that confirms it right
I mean that confirms when Dickon was
born but again you know it's kind of a
cool little history there it's it's sort
of out there I mean I really hope that
one of the things that that Hickman does
as part of his x-men run its create this
almost kind of zero hour crisis and time
from DC sort of map where we get this
chronological history of the mutant
population so many sort of edged in
stone and so instead of having to do
like we do here where we basically go
through like 50 60 even a hundred
different color books to basically sort
of try to pick out these little bits of
history and so on and so forth nimma say
we have it like one single cohesive
place but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]